so
all right welcome everybody we have a
lot of things to discuss uh
very very much glad that you're joining
me kind of just wrapping up the week a
bunch of things did happen in the last
24 hours some of which we got to on
today's podcast which
uh went out about an hour ago and many
many things that didn't
so i'm glad to have the opportunity to
talk about um
other things that are going on but the
big news is that donald trump yesterday
as we were just wrapping yesterday's
stream
delivered this video uh which was
really one of the most pathetic sort of
concessions
but it it really is a concession and
that trump is now saying in completely
certain terms there will be a transition
and there were some sort of like q
people and other conspiracy theorists
who were saying you know trump doesn't
really say
transition to biden but
the reason trump doesn't say that isn't
because he has some secret plan to stay
it's because he just can't be an adult
and mention joe biden beat me
um and we have subsequently learned so
the story is starting with this video
last night
this is as close to a concession as
we're going to get from anybody thanks
david chadman for the 10 gifted by the
way
then donald trump um tweeted
again more sort of allusions to the
election being stolen
then trump uh tweeted he will not be
going to joe biden's inauguration
then joe biden said that's fine and then
nancy pelosi said
um that they're looking at impeaching
trump if he doesn't resign and indeed we
may be seeing a second donald trump
impeachment
i believe trump would be the only
president to be impeached twice right
is that i guess i should have googled
that um
has any president been impeached twice
um no president has been impeached twice
so that is correct yeah all right so we
we may be heading to that and and i know
that
i i don't want to put the cart before
the horse but there's already people
saying there's no point in impeaching
him twice and it would be divisive so it
shouldn't be done
i think that's a terrible argument but i
have clips planned for that so i don't
want to jump into that
right away okay chaka seki's pointing
out via super chat that trump's
concession video demonstrates multiple
camera angles and cuts likely because it
was interrupted by tantrums
as he begged for chicken tenders yeah i
don't know that it was begging for
chicken tenders and i don't know that it
was tan terms but
but clearly it was pieced together from
multiple takes
and his frustration with the fact that
he was he was doing this it
may be part of it the report is that the
reason we're gonna look at the video i
know
this is a big lead up um the um
the the the reason that this is
a uh a big deal and the reason that he
even did this
is reportedly because he was told if you
don't do
something like this you're going to get
removed either
by the 25th amendment or in some other
way although then there were conflicting
reports that pence has not actually
spoken to cabinet members about the 25th
amendment
and then there were conflicting reports
that pence did speak with cabinet
members but said he wouldn't go for the
25th amendment
what's the truth we don't know
conflicting reports as as of this point
in time
so let's go chronologically if we if we
can
let me make sure we're going to have uh
be all set up in terms of volume
all right let's listen by addressing the
heinous attack
on the united states capital like all
americans i am
outraged by the violence lawlessness
and mayhem that apparently is not true
trump apparently loved it and even
resisted bringing in the national guard
he loved the mayhem and he loved the
violence from the reports we've gotten
so far
i immediately deployed the national
guard that apparently is also a lie the
reports are that trump
resisted deploying the national guard
against his own supporters
and it was mike pence that ultimately
made that call so so far we're 14
seconds in
at least three probable lies and federal
law enforcement
to secure the building and expel the
intruders
america is and must always be a nation
of law
and order right but so he keeps
repeating that but he clearly doesn't
mean it
the demonstrators who infiltrated the
capital
have defiled the seat of american
democracy
that's true to those who engage in the
acts of violence and destruction
you do not represent our country and to
those who broke the law
you will pay i hope that that's the case
we have just been through an intense
election and emotions are high
but now tempers must be cooled and calm
restored we must get on with the
business
of america my campaign vigorously
pursued every legal avenue
to contest even some that are dubiously
legal
the election results my only goal was to
ensure the integrity of the vote
in so doing i was fine that's obviously
a lie his goal is evidenced
by everything we saw including asking
the georgia republican officials to find
11 000 votes
his priority was to find enough votes so
that he would win
fighting to defend american democracy
i continue to strongly believe that we
must reform our
election laws to verify the identity and
eligibility of all voters
and to ensure faith and confidence in
all
future elections now congress has
certified the results
a new administration will be inaugurated
on january 20th
now that is the that's where what's
really going on there is trump can't
bring himself to say
president-elect joe biden's
administration that's why he's not
saying joe biden
there are trumpian folks who are
interpreting trump saying
a new administration will be sworn in as
code for
my new administration but that's
obviously not going to be the case
oh sorry here we go my focus now turns
to ensuring a smooth orderly and
seamless transition of power
now what's funny about that is he's now
being called presidential for saying
that
but it's january 8th right we're almost
nine weeks
into doing the opposite of ensuring an
orderly and peaceful transition
this is sort of like uh oh what was the
analogy
i saw oh my there was such a great
analogy to
you know they're they're they're
abandoning the ship some of his uh
followers some of his uh um
cabinet members and others they're
abandoning the ship with 12 days to go
uh oh i forget what the analogy was it
was let me i'll if i remember it i'll
come back to it
this moment calls for healing and
reconciliation
2020 has been a challenging time for our
people
a menacing pandemic has upended the
lives of our citizens
isolated millions in their homes damaged
our economy
and claimed countless lives defeating
this pandemic and rebuilding the
greatest economy on earth
will require all of us working together
that's funny because trump claims to
have already rebuilt the economy
it will require a renewed emphasis on
the civic values of patriotism
faith charity community and family
we must revitalize the sacred bonds of
love and loyalty
so this is all kind of just meaningless
disingenuous stuff that bind us together
as one national family to the citizens
of our country
serving as your president has been the
honor of my lifetime
and to all of my wonderful supporters i
know you are disappointed
but i also want you to know that our
incredible journey
is only just beginning thank you
god bless you and god bless america so
uh this is uh i don't know if you want
to call this a hostage video thanks for
the 10 gifted by the way david chadman i
appreciate that
um is this a hostage video is this
a i don't want to be removed video
but as far as we've been told donald
trump reluctantly did this
and of course it's all disingenuous
because he was convinced you really may
be removed before january
20th if you don't do something something
something like this
as albert is pointing out it feels like
a toddler being forced to apologize
uh and then and people want to see the
tweets yeah so we're gonna get to that
um i'm being told uh the justin trudeau
trump statement
is important so we're going to look at
that momentarily
let me see if i filter by upload date
uh yep okay here it is so we're going to
look at that momentarily
um but okay so let's go through the
sequel a
of this and i i am determined not to
fall behind on thank you so big thank
you to the
33 twitch subscribers
33 that's very strong and also
thanks to the four uh
subscribers at joinpakman.com four
people and you know what since it's only
four i'll be able to thank them by name
thanks to josh smithson tucker carlson
no i'm kidding tucker bergentino
um haley martinez and lynn prince i
appreciate that
that uh okay so trump first does
that very strange video then after
posting that
he tweets this morning more of what i
call
agitrash the 75 million great american
patriots who voted for me
america first and make america great
again
will have a giant voice long into the
future
they will not be disrespected or treated
unfairly in any way shape or form
okay who i don't even whatever you know
who even knows what the meaning of that
is
but then more importantly donald trump
tweeting to
all of those who have asked i will not
be going to the inauguration of january
20th
and so this is of course very
unpresidential but i don't care
we really don't need him there we've
already scheduled our coverage of joe
biden's inauguration on january 20th
it's like good um and the latest
reporting is that
the first family is actually planning to
leave washington dc
on a january 19th not even going to
stick around
for inauguration day okay so that's the
latest now
after that we got a report
that nancy pelosi is threatening
impeachment if donald trump doesn't
resign immediately
we may be getting in the direction of an
impeach express
impeachment uh you know how you can like
get now they have some kinds of plastic
surgery you can get during your lunch
break and you go back to work
uh so i've read anyway uh the house
could vote on impeachment next week we
may see
we you know facelift express we may see
an impeachment express here
the house could vote on impeachment next
week president trump will not attend
president-elect joe biden's inauguration
let's look at that article um speaker
nancy pelosi threatened
that the house could move to impeach
trump over his role in inciting a
violent mob attack on the capitol if he
did not resign
immediately appealing to republicans to
push the uh
to join the push to force him from
office in a letter to members of the
house the speaker invoked the
resignation of richard nixon
amid the watergate scandal when
republicans prevailed upon the president
to resign and avoid the
ignominy of an impeachment calling mr
trump's actions
a horrific assault on our democracy
today following the president's
dangerous and seditious acts republicans
in congress need to follow that example
and call on trump to depart his office
immediately if the president does not
leave office a minute
imminently and willingly the congress
will proceed
with our actions so that would be uh
it would be fantastic to see donald
trump impeach the second time
i will get to the objection that it
would be divisive i think that's a
terrible justification for not doing it
but we will get to that
uh pelosi also said she had spoken with
general mark milley the chairman of the
joint chiefs about preventing an
unstable president from initiating
military hostilities or accessing
the launch codes also an important
concern
a spokesman for milli confirmed that the
two had spoken
and said the general answered her
questions regarding the process of
nuclear command authority my belief is
if for whatever i don't believe trump
will do it it's absurd that trump is too
too much of a loose cannon to post to
facebook but he has the nukes
the new codes um but i don't believe
that that trump will actually try to
launch nukes
i also believe if he did that at this
point in time the
the highest levels of the military
understand
that uh this is an unstable person and i
don't even think they would allow
nukes to be launched i don't think it's
going to be
uh an issue and then oh no we'll we'll
get to that a little bit later so let me
not i don't want to jump ahead of where
where we are okay so that's basically
what's happened over the last 24 hours
now
i want to get to joe biden's reaction to
this
i should answer some questions first um
i should answer some questions before i
move on because once i get into this
it's going to be a pretty
pretty deep dive um
david your broadcast is super blurry
both your face and the content are
unreadable
never happened to me before yeah every
everything's fine i would just refresh
um but ever we're broadcasting in hd and
everything's going fine
trump stops short of conceding and ends
the speech with it's only just the
beginning he has a scheme in mind and
it's probably a crazy one
maybe but he'll be gone on the 20th
that's that's it
uh question david how do you combat the
unwillingness to so much as discuss
toxicity within the left that alienates
radicalized people towards the right
um i talk about toxicity within the left
all the time
i've not stopped short of that um
yeah so i don't know you'd have to talk
to somebody who is is stopping short of
that but i am not
i am not stopping short of that okay
let's continue joe biden
did react to the news that donald trump
will not be attending the president
the inauguration oh wait what's this
what is this
oh is this lindsey graham getting
confronted at the airport
[Music]
is this tsa having to protect him oh no
that looks like customs and border
border patrol uh or um yeah customs
these are these are anti-trump people
right people are saying how are these
trump nuts allowed
it seems to me these are anti-trump
people berating lindsey graham
oh these are trumpers these are trumpers
that are mad at lindsey graham because
he eventually
accepted that joe biden won is that is
that what this is going
that's is that what's happening here
they're pro okay yeah okay fair i
understand
i understand lindsay didn't do enough
for i see so it's actually even crazier
because lindsey graham is out of his
mind
[Applause]
[Music]
wow eaten alive by the monster he helped
create that's amazing
okay so let's see i want to get to the
joe biden
statement about uh okay here is biden
okay here are the two clips okay let's
take a listen to this this is the first
one biden reacting to trump won't go to
his inauguration on the way up here
way over here that he indicated he
wasn't going to show up
at the uh at the inauguration one of the
few things he and i have ever agreed on
oh that's good good thing i'm not
showing up
earlier you'd said that if uh you'd hope
that he would show up
only in the sense that it was valuable
to send a signal to the world about the
transfer of power
you've clearly changed your perspective
on that because he has clearly
demonstrated he's exceeded even my worst
notions about him
right he's been an embarrassment to the
country
embarrassed us around the world not
worthy not worthy to hold that office
if we were six months out we should be
moving
everything to get him out of office and
teaching them again
invoke trying to invoke the 25th
amendment whatever it took right
to get him out of office wow nice but i
am focused now
on us taking control as president and
vice president
on the 20th and to get our agenda moving
as quickly as we can so biden
thinks it's good that trump won't be
going to the inauguration i quite
frankly agree it'll just be a
distraction
and then asked about the possibility of
mike pence going uh
says that's fine and that it's a good
thing that uh the president is not
coming but what about
the vice president mike pence welcome
i think it's important that um the
as much as we can stick to what have
been
the historical precedence of how in the
circumstance in which
an administration changes should be
maintained you know one of the things i
i don't want to get i don't
we'll continue one of the things is
that's very interesting about joe biden
is he's actually better at speaking
extemporaneously
in answering questions as many of you
know joe biden has struggled with a
stutter since he was young
and that seems to manifest more when
he's reading a a written speech
this is really where joe biden is best
from my perspective where he's just
talking
and responding to questions at what
tends to be
more length than than what we've seen
from the trump administration
and so if mike if the vice president
is welcome to come he'd be honored to
have him there
and uh and to move forward in the
transition
have you spoken to him at all no i
haven't wow what
that's a clear answer and then lastly um
here is donald uh trump being called not
fit to serve by joe biden during this
um question and answer session earlier
today which i found quite interesting
pick up on something that you just said
about president trump actively
encouraging the insurrection at the
capitol
given that given the perceived threat
that he poses
my question to you is not so much about
the role that congress should play an
impeachment but rather
should president trump in your
estimation remain in office
i didn't think look i've been saying
for now well over a year he is not
fit to serve he is not fit to serve
he's one of the most incompetent
presidents in the history of the united
states of america
and so the idea that i think he
shouldn't be out of office yesterday
is not the issue the question is
what happens with 14 days left to go or
13 days left to go
and i think that what 81 million people
stood up and said
it's time for him to go and the united
states
senate voted 93 to 6
to confirm that we should be sworn in
we were we were duly elected so i think
it's important we get on with the
business
getting him out of office and then this
also came up earlier
and let me get to that clip because i
don't actually
think this is a great um let me see
here uh
yeah okay here it is so i'm gonna play
chris wallace making this point because
a lot of people have been making it this
is a point about the possible
impeachment of trump or
removal under the 25th what from what i
hear from republicans on the hill people
in the white house
they feel that that any kind of removal
at this point would probably create
more harm uh more more
outrage uh than it would than it would
damp down that it would stall
uh obviously there are millions of
people who supported donald trump
there are 100 i think this is a bad
reason not to do it so
i i don't have a problem with
considering the the
uh pragmatic effect of our of our
actions right so
it's not that i think we should ignore
the consequences of an action
you you consider the consequences of an
action in determining whether it's the
right action or the wrong action it's
not
you consider the means and you evaluate
the ends and you think about it all
this is not one of those things where we
say listen
most presidents don't deserve to be
removed
most presidents don't deserve to be
impeached
most presidents even if you disagree
with them politically
are not fundamentally unfit to serve
most right so for me you
it is it is not a good argument to say
well
a president sure yeah he what he did
deserves impeachment but there's only 14
days left and some people might get mad
it might be divisive no no
it's too big an issue it's too important
it has to be that when a president
deserves to be impeached they are
impeached
it must be that when a president is
unfit to serve
they must be removed via the 25th
amendment and so now saying
oh it would be divisive and it would
he's leaving anyway we it's a
calculation
you you you account for the consequences
and the impact
i think these are this is a bad reason i
think this would be a very bad reason
not to do it that's my perspective
and i'm fine hearing from others and and
i also see the idea that if you do it
you make
trump a martyr nah nah he's already a
martyr
um the the the tens of millions of
people who believe he really won and
that it was stolen
they already see him as a martyr um so i
don't
that i don't i don't that that's not um
compelling to me
i think is the point that uh i'm trying
to make okay so that's as far as the
clips
go uh those clips
um let me see what else i had
um oh okay
yeah we so there's this other thing
where
in the midst of all of this simon and
schuster has decided not to go forward
with a book by senator josh hawley and
josh hawley is one of the main
he was like sort of the i believe he was
the first republican senator who said he
would actually object
to the count to the ballot count and now
simon and schuster
republicans are against business
regulation simon schuster as a business
free to decide what's good for them said
we don't want to do a book for this guy
and this has now become you know the
free speech battle
um take a listen to this from fox news
your reaction
yeah so i i disagree with him a little
bit here and here's why first of all the
first amendment involves the government
prohibiting speech this is not a first
amendment issue this is a private
company that's right
simon and schuster whether you agree
with the decision or not this is like a
we finally have some sense talked on fox
news
and you can see these other five people
particularly brian kill me looks like
he's had some bad clams as he hears this
simon schuster is a private company and
they can decide at any point that they
want to stop
and they don't want to go through and
for example this is the way to look at
it if i got if i were in the midst
of a deal and i had a publishing deal
and i got on tv today and said something
outrageous
racist whatever it may be a publishing
company can give me a call and
contractually say
we don't want to put money and blood
sweat and tears into your book we don't
want to back it that's well within their
right
i also think i know that the impulse is
to say
by the way don't don't i have a right to
have simon and schuster publish my book
is that not censorship
if they don't publish my book this is
orwellian but for me it's actually the
opposite it's orwellian
to think that anyone would be able to
tell a private company that
they need it's these republicans who for
decades have said we can't be telling
private companies what to do
we that would that that's oppressive
it's
she's abs i've never heard commentary
this good on fox news
it would be orwellian to go and tell
simon shuster
you can't bail on josh hawley's stupid
book
publish your book or it's a first
amendment violation so i think he has
this wrong and i'm taking aside what i
believe was atrocious behavior on his
part with respect to the election this
isn't about
now i see people in the chat saying this
is the same thing the nfl
did um over uh you're calling kaepernick
that's right it it's true but what you
have to understand
is we as consumers are also part of the
free market of ideas so
what i'm saying is simon schuster is
completely
free to back out of this
and if we are mad at simon schuster if
we believe
what simon and schuster did is really
bad we can say hey we're going to
boycott simon schuster's books
we're going to punish simon and schuster
because we wanted them to publish josh
hawley's book we're going to we're going
to punish them
the nfl the the problem i have with what
the nfl did is that there appears to
have been
collusion between teams for no one
to hire go ahead and hire colin
kaepernick and that's a disaster
we can't deny that any team individually
can say
we don't want colin kaepernick on our
team because we've made a business
decision that
his kneeling and his activism is bad for
they can do that
the collusion between owners is what i
have a problem with from the standpoint
of the nfl but again there's also a
consumer reaction
consumers can say if we don't agree with
what the nfl teams did
then we can boycott them now of course
when the teams
when the team owners are colluding
you're talking about something else
and you could make the argument that
that's all that that to some degree that
could almost be like
uh price fixing in a sense and it gets a
little more complicated but
we have to be consistent with this stuff
and that's the thing with these right
it's not that difficult to actually
figure out what the consistent position
is okay
so that's um that's fox news and
uh oh just just one other one other all
of a sudden
fox news is all about feelings it's
we are disheartened we are upset
and ainslie earhart continues to play
this thing about just the the way all of
these trumpists are feeling it's like
how do you think everybody else felt
when they stormed the capitol violently
you know there were 75 million people
that voted for president trump and
they're scared they're worried about
what the future of this country looks
like
many of them they're confused they are
they're confused they're heartbroken
that their candidate didn't win
and they don't want to be forgotten and
tucker carlson really hit
hit home with us last night listen okay
and then and then
last thing here and we're going to get
to some of tucker stuff this uh aaron
rupar pointed this out
fox news is doing this thing now ainsley
earhart just did it and trace gallagher
did it with i think this is howie kurtz
um fox news you so
oh do we even want to do this right now
i don't even know if we want to do this
i i'll do a brief version of it
for a bit because there's such a bigger
story here one of the things
fox news has done for a long time is
claim that they have an opinion side and
a news side
okay people are saying to do it and some
people are saying not to do this
so fox news says listen we have an
opinion side and a new side they must be
evaluated separately
on the on the opinion side people have
opinions and we have some right wing
people there but the news side is simply
news and one of the things fox news has
done for a really long time is blur the
lines between that
they'll have their opinion people on the
news shows to give their opinion but it
really looks like news
and they deliberately blur the lines
between what's news and what's opinion
and of course because of the media
literacy
deficit we have in this country a lot of
people don't realize it
this is something else they do which is
they take
the opinion stuff and during the news
hours
they report it as if it they it is it
becomes news
hey here is a news report the opinion
person
said the following and that's what they
do here this is america's newsroom
reporting on tucker blasting the media's
obsession with trump
so again this is another thing where
if we had you know stronger media
literacy infrastructure in this country
people wouldn't fall for this stuff and
i think that that's really important to
know
uh okay very good let me we're gonna go
to the trudeau video next i do wanna say
thank you to the
three additional twitch subscribers and
they are
step 12 12 step signing up from
germany i appreciate that the classy
crane
and um some of the gifts coming in still
from david chadman i appreciate that
very much
and then also want to say thank you over
on our
website to simon mcgrath for signing up
at joinedpakman.com jonathan berentine
randy miller austin delp
maxwell solomon and daniel guo
which puts us at 46
i very much appreciate that and yes the
coupon code works i i realized that
there was a sort of a
mismatch in coupon codes in different
places the 2021 coupon code is that one
better 21.
okay so let's get to the true actually
do you want me to do
oh that's funny so some people are
asking for repeater
voicemails you might find this funny
since democrats won the senate and the
armed insurrection
i haven't received one voicemail from re
peter
over the last two three weeks i received
over a hundred voicemails from re
peter and i've not heard he
he's just disappeared uh since democrats
won georgia
and um and the armed insurrection
i don't i don't know if i will ever hear
from him again
but i'm looking at the voicemail right
now
yeah nothing just nothing from repeater
oh wait
oh wait a second oh no no no no i did
i got one this man i've lost
it's over with hold on this might be
repeater let me see here
whoops that's muted hold on sorry i
might have one repeater signing off
uh this is van i've left it's the same
area code sorry no it's not repeater
yeah we have not heard anything from
repeater since democrats won everything
so that's that okay all right let's go
to the justin trudeau video this is
uh canadian prime minister justin
trudeau i would say
let's do it in let's do the french one
he tip i love how he does most of these
in in
french and then recuts does another cut
in english but just for today
we'll stick with the english one to
begin by addressing what unfolded in
washington dc this week
what we witnessed was an assault on
democracy
by violent rioters incited by the
current president
is one of these sign language
interpreters it's
is one doing american sign language and
the other is french
this is very interesting i've never seen
simultaneous uh
that's very interesting can french and
english sign language that's compelling
i love that okay here we go sorry and
other politicians
as shocking deeply disturbing and
frankly
saddening as that event remains we've
also seen
this week that democracy is resilient
in america our closest ally and neighbor
violence has no place in our societies
can we by
i don't i know that this is so
irrelevant in the tough times we're
facing right now
that beard is really well done uh it
looks like it fades i mean maybe he
just that's genetically how it grows but
it looks like it fades up towards the
cheeks
and it has the perfect amount of gray
right on the chin
and absolutely uh no uh oh maybe there
anyway let's continue and extremists
will not succeed
in overruling the will of the people
that's right as canadians
i think we've been all reflecting on our
own country
something i spoke with the premiers
about last night
about the fact that democracy is not
automatic it takes work every day
about what a real accomplishment it is
to maintain a political system
in which the losing side gracefully
concedes
and in which rival political parties
between elections
work together right for the common good
we have this in canada because canadians
make it possible that that is some shade
that is some serious shade at trump is
for sure right there
it but it but it's almost too subtle for
the average trump is to understand that
i think
i don't i think that goes over the head
of the average trumpist it's so subtle
canadians expect their political leaders
to protect our
precious democracy right by how we
conduct ourselves
we have seen this manifest in unanimous
consent in our parliament for our main
covet fighting measures at a time when
the government holds a minority of seats
we see it in the cooperation between the
federal government and
provincial and territorial governments
regardless of
political stripe canadians
expect debate debate in service of
all canadians debate that is grounded in
a shared acceptance
of the facts in a diverse country
there will always be diverse
perspectives and it is through
respect for those differences that we
create
a stronger canada canadian democracy
didn't happen by accident and it won't
continue
without work we must always work to
secure our democracy
and not give comfort to those who
promote things that are not true
or give space for hatred i
i think that they give space is very
important because when you look at now
the the rats abandoning the sinking ship
these republicans who
gave the space that's the exact phrase
where
even some of them who never said they
liked the stuff
trump was doing they continued to give
the space and i
i like the use of that term extremism
very very nice whoa now it's
recommending jordan peterson content
we're not going to do that
um very very well said uh by justin
trudeau there um i like i like the
statement quite a bit
so thanks thanks for pointing me in that
direction
i do um i i do appreciate that
okay good uh i did want to take a brief
look at
what was happening on uh is this newsmax
or oan you can't ever tell this is
newsmax
so no surprise it sounds like they're
still
talking about the election being quote
stolen on newsmax they they may never go
away they seem to have a panel
let's just for a second just for a
second
let's look at what they're what they're
talking about 74 plus million i would go
on to say it's probably 100 120 million
americans
who are questioning the integrity of the
election and are questioning the power
of their vote
so this guy's got a 9 9 12 was some
wacky glenn beck-affiliated movement
years ago
seeing someone with the not 9 12 the two
the things that concern me here are
this guy's sweatshirt the lower third
talking about election integrity and the
expression on this guy's face those are
the of
overtly concerning things right now they
would deal with this problem head-on
they would address it and they would do
it in a way that the american people can
truly believe
that their vote matters last word
heather yeah and they don't believe that
right now
um mitt romney said the best
way to respect voters is to tell them
the truth i believe the best way to
respect voters
is to fix any irregularities any fraud
any mistakes human error or otherwise
it doesn't matter if it's widespread or
not it doesn't matter if it happens in
every election
quit kicking the can down the road and
also the other thing they can do
is you know what's funny about that is
all of the efforts made and placed in
front of mitch mcconnell
over the last four years to deal with
foreign interference in elections
mitch mcconnell just did nothing with he
wouldn't even bring them to the floor of
the senate so it's it's it's so
it's i i can't call it disingenuous
because these people may be so ignorant
that they don't know that that stuff
happened we
i don't want i i try to be careful not
to assume
malice when they might just be ignorant
they may have no idea that it's actually
republicans who have prevented and
they've kicked the can down the road but
who knows who knows the these people are
truly uh truly unbelievable
okay a few other things um
be oh okay sorry hold on big thank you
to the 17
additional twitch uh subscribers
which puts us at um 57
very very much appreciate that and also
a big thanks to zach russell for signing
up at jointpakman.com
alana bryant hans charler
olay joakim jersen
i know i butchered that and chris
villarreal
very much appreciate those subscriptions
as well
which puts us at 62 and uh yeah i'll
open i'll open some phone lines i'm glad
to open phone lines if we if we get to
100 i think we may
real quick one other thing i wanted to
play for you guys we had a really funny
we had a fast turnaround on a meme
yesterday we got a great caller from
scotland and i
i mean i was interested in sort of like
the dialect spoken in scotland so i
asked what do you how do you refer to
what we what i grew up referring to soda
carbonated beverages um and it it was
kind of funny this is just a piece of
that we already have a song parody based
on this so
this is from the call yesterday let me
see if i can i really want to get an
answer here to the question i'm trying
to ask which is
if we talk are you familiar with the
beverage sprite
yes okay the category is sprite
a soda is it a pop is it a coke
what is the category under which you
would put sprite
um i would call it i would call it like
fizzy i suppose or like a ginger i would
just call it ginger right
um i don't i don't know what anyone else
would call it
i think we just use it interchangeably
um like i don't i don't know if we
differentiate between like
pop or soda or physio certainly we just
kind of like thrown into the one kind of
category and then just call it ginger i
suppose and are you saying i want to
make sure you're
when you say are you saying the word
that's spelled g-i-n-g-e-r
that's the word yes so ginger hair um
you know that's that's how we refer to i
suppose
so my mind is blown i'm not gonna lie my
mind is okay so anyway
that's already been turned into a song
and i have it for you
uh right here take a listen to this
[Music]
let's go to larry from glasgow
hello how are you hi david
i love phone calls from scotland
scotland
[Music]
carbonated beverages do you call them
soda pop coke what do you call it
[Music]
fizzy juice or pot or soda are called
ginger or
orange juice orange juice
we refer to orange as ginger in scotland
you call every soda a coke ginger we
call that gender
and our fizzy dress fizzy juice
what you're saying
some people call every soda coke ginger
but you mean orange juice by by coke
what okay anyway so that's um
that that's that uh all right so um
one of the great things i i i'm being
told that lisa murkowski may be leaving
the republican party so we're going to
get to that in a second that actually is
a major story but i just want to point
out something very very interesting
um one of the great things about
uh i don't know i guess about doing this
is that
people in the audience feel so strongly
in opposition about anything that
happens
on this show okay here's an example will
says david pausing trudeau's speech to
complement his beard
is my favorite part of 2021 so far
okay on the other hand
while we did that chapa from argentina
says is this mf seriously going on about
trudeau's beard
diametrically opposed positions
about that someone loves it and someone
doesn't and by the way
anytime i see a super chat come in
some of you know i was born in argentina
um
50 argentinian pesos it's so tragic what
has gone on
with the currency in argentina um yeah
as people are pointing out that's like
50 cents
it's it's truly tragic what has been
going on in argentina and people who
have not been well served
uh by any recent government by any
recent government
and uh i mean listen now you you
literally have
delusional lunatics back in place
previously you had
you know this wacky center rightist um
it's just it's really really sad and uh
yeah that's about 50 cents at this point
actually let's let's look up exactly how
much it is right now
um 50 ars to usd
at 59 cents okay yeah yeah it's it's
insane what's been going on
with the the currency there um
yeah alfonsine was decent that's
absolutely true
and i see sunlight and leaves in the
twitch chat
with some uh knowledge of argentinian
history very very
interesting stuff i appreciate that okay
breaking news uh lisa murkowski may quit
the republican party and of course if
that happens
that puts democrats in a much stronger
position
in the senate alaska senator lisa
murkowski calls on trump to resign
questions her future as a republican a
republican senator
demanding the republican president desi
resign
that has escalated that is we have now
entered a new
i don't know what to call it stage in
all of this u.s senator lisa murkowski
said friday that donald trump should
resign the presidency immediately
and that if the republican party cannot
separate itself from trump
she isn't certain she has a future with
the party i want him to resign
i want him out he has caused enough
damage
wow i think he should leave he said he's
not going to show up he's not going to
appear at the inauguration he hasn't
been focused on what's going on with
covid
he's either been golfing or he's been
inside the oval office fuming and
throwing every single person who has
been
loyal and faithful to him under the bus
starting with the vice president he
doesn't want to stay there he only wants
to stay there for the title
he only wants to stay there for his ego
he needs to get out
he needs to do the good thing but i
don't think he's capable of doing a good
thing
this is very interesting murkowski said
that while there may have been many many
many good americans who came from
washington
who came to d.c because they felt
strongly in support of trump
trump incited them to storm the capital
that's absolutely true i will attribute
it to the president who said even after
his vice president told him that morning
i do not have the constitutional
authority to do what you have asked me
to do i cannot do it i have to protect
and uphold the constitution
even after the vice president told
president trump that he still told his
supporters to fight
how are they supposed to take that it's
an order from the president and so
that's what they did
they came up and fought and people were
harmed and jordan died asked whether she
intends to remain a republican she said
that
depends on the party you know there's a
lot of people who actually thought that
i did that in 2010
think that i became an independent i
didn't have any reason to leave my party
in 2010.
i was a republican who ran a write-in
campaign and i was successful but i will
tell you
if the republican party has become
nothing more than the party of trump
i sincerely question whether this is the
party for me
so listen that's great but where was she
on impeachment nothing has changed
we called this the day after trump was
elected in 2016.
and we said it was it would get this bad
and then you had everything that you had
in the interim
and now she says oh i might become an
independent and trump should go
where where was she on impeachment she
uh
lisa murkowski much like susan collins
is perpetually
concerned about what i heard from the
president and
dismayed or worried
and then she just says no no no we're
not we're not going to impeach
and by the way when she says maybe you
know when we're talking about
independent
that doesn't even necessarily mean it
would be a vote for
to to caucus with democrats bernie is an
independent but he caucuses with the
democrats so
this is very interesting it's it's that
a republican senator is calling for a
republican president to resign it is a
big deal
but it's much easier to do it when
there's 12 days left and as people are
pointing out
too little too late too little too late
she should leave her office and pay back
her salary i like that
i like that mr wizard that's a that's a
fair absolutely fair point
okay so that we got
we did the scottish call we did
uh oh i haven't done this yet so do you
want me
to go through some super chats or do we
want to hear a c-span caller in tears
wondering if trump lied to her where do
we want to go
i'm being advised to sell my bitcoin and
my tesla stock
um let's see where are either of them
where where is bitcoin right now btc
usd is at 40k all right that's nice
um quite a run-up
and where is tesla right now
whoops tesla is
up um was up seven percent today again
wow
yeah i've been in tesla since 2015.
um oh this doesn't even go that far back
that's crazy uh yeah i think it was
february of 15 that i got into tesla
yeah right around here it's nuts i mean
it's crazy what's going on it's really
unbelievable
um and i sold i panic sold half
in 17 or 18. when was the thing where
elon musk
smoked pot with joe rogan and it looked
like maybe he was gonna get room
was it this dip right here i don't even
remember when that was
but i sold half of it at that point
obviously i shouldn't have done that
that was not smart that was not smart
all right here we go uh let's take a
listen apparently this is a caller in
tears over the possibility that trump
might have um
might might have lied to her let's take
a listen let's make sure we have proper
audio
we need proper modulation tammy's in
boise idaho
hi tammy what are your thoughts about
today i just have one question
i wanted to know if my president lied to
me today
and if he did i want me him to tell me
and more importantly
i want him to tell the family of the
woman that
got shot and killed today wow i voted
for him
i voted for him
i'm sorry
okay uh wow what an expression
i'm sorry i'm gonna excuse me while i do
show prep because since it's friday i do
want to send myself some of these
stories for monday
um okay so i wanted to cover this
that is something i want to listen to
that one more time in a second
uh and i also want to cover murkowski
might leave
and says trump resign
okay i i definitely want to be covering
those stories
on monday let's let's listen to this one
more time i see some people saying this
is a joke
i i mean i can't tell i don't know it it
could be a joke
the problem is at this point this has
all been indistinguishable from parody
so this
this could be a complete joke or it
might be someone who has all of a sudden
realized trump's been lying for four
years
tammy's in boise idaho hi tammy what are
your thoughts about today
i just have one question i wanted to
know
if my president lied to me today and if
he did i want me
him to tell me and more importantly i
want him to tell the family of the woman
that
got shot and killed today i voted for
him
i voted for him
i'm sorry
that's tammy and boise okay i mean it's
very interesting and who it
that just as easily could be a joke as
it could be real i mean i
i really have no idea but a lot of
people were were absolutely conned by uh
by by this president
okay i have some clips from tucker's
show last
night to look at we'll get to that in a
moment
um let me just quickly say thanks to
uh the six folks who just grabbed twitch
prime subs putting us at 68.
and then the additional five people who
signed up at joinpakman.com putting us
at 73.
i see people are trying to call me right
now
but the phone lines are not open at this
point i am
up to opening the phone lines we've got
a very sensible goal of a hundred
and then we can look at opening opening
those up the coupon code is working i
see people telling me the coupon code is
not working
um the coupon code's working fine it's
user error okay
user error the coupon code only works
at joinpakman.com it seems people are
trying to use the coupon code on twitch
that doesn't work
doesn't work this is a good question
will trump pardon any of the rioters
you know um he can't pardon anybody
unless he knows who to pardon
and that's why um it may take some time
to get all of the rioters
charged and that could actually prevent
trump from pardoning them
uh so that's that's pretty compelling
morris
says ginger ale root beer ginger is a
type of root
ale is a type of beer so is ginger ale a
type of root beer
fantastic fantastic question joe raider
says that chamath polypitia says tesla
will go another two to three x from here
yeah i mean listen i'm either going down
with the ship
or i'm uh what's the opposite of going
down with the ship just staying afloat i
don't know
but yeah i i'm i'm in i'm in
and who knows what it is that that will
happen as far as that goes
okay let's get to some of these clips
from tucker carlson from
last night let's make sure we get all of
them as in as close to high definition
as we can
uh here is part of tucker's monologue
they'll then we'll get to a bit of an
interview
um with i guess uh i guess marco rubio
i've been advised that we should be
looking at this
um all right let's let's take a listen
here's tucker
right now serious people are upset about
what happened
yesterday in washington they want to
figure out exactly what happened and
they want to know
why it happened but none of the people
should be asking are asking instead
they're taking the opportunity to mock
the people
who were there that's not true that's
completely untrue
um i mean my coverage and that of uh
of of much of the corporate media
reporting i've even seen
is a combination of uh how did this even
happen
what what exactly was law enforcement
thinking how did this end up taking
place
and the fact that trump and his cronies
incited it
and the fact that these people need to
to be held accountable and take personal
i mean no that's that's absolutely not
true
because they're from the wrong social
class oh god kim
there are people who flew on a private
jet
to participate in the insurrection this
is social cl
now all of it see this is exact we
talked about this yesterday and it's
happening again
this is the issue with this faux
populist it's not faux populism
the populist rhetoric on the left and
right that gets very mixed up and
jumbled like it's in a
you know in a clothes washer um tucker
has this populist rhetoric and that's
how he ends up having people on
who are left populists and they're all
getting along and it's just all great
these people they they both think
they're using it each other and in fact
it's just a mess
um no just no as events unfolded
yesterday one cnn anchor who by the way
is the son of a vanderbilt which is
relevant oh now he's talking about
anderson cooper
you may have blue jeans made it explicit
trump supporters are bad
because they eat at lowbrow restaurants
look at them they're high-fiving each
other for this deplorable display
of of completely unpatriotic
completely against law and order
completely
unconstitutional behavior so far
anderson's exactly right let's listen
it's stunning and they're gonna go back
you know to the olive garden and to
their
the holiday inn that they're staying at
in the garden marriott
and they're gonna have some drinks and
they're gonna talk about the great day
that they had in washington and they
really did something and stand up
i mean listen he he i i
okay i mean maybe saying holiday inn
and olive garden is um is is an attack
but
the he's actually right in the greater
point which is
they believe that this is a victory
that's the greater point they
they believe this is a victory yeah it's
a bit condescending olive garden's a
disaster i agree with that and it's not
a financial thing and i've always said
this before olive garden's not super
cheap
there are places that cost the same as
olive garden but they're good it's more
of a cultural thing than if i
think it's more of a cultural thing than
a financial thing uh i think olive
garden is a disaster i i like the attack
on olive garden that i like i have to
tell you
and it's not a financial thing you can
find i mean look
in dc olive garden and a local italian
place
uh you you're talking about a very
similar price range not the hot not the
most expensive italian place
um all of olive garden is a disaster
and i will stand by that um okay
anyway the great i think the greater
point it's condescending it's true
but the greater point here is um the the
that uh
anderson is right that they view this as
a success they're going to go and have
drinks
probably with no masks on and think that
they they scored a victory here and
that's a real problem that's scary
for something and they stood up for
nothing other than
mayhem it's just class war by another
name and never has it been more clear
than in that clip by the way how much do
you appreciate the lecture on
patriotism and law and order from cnn
well
tucker gives those lessons and lectures
all the time see this is what this is
what's very interesting
because tucker is maybe tucker's right
that it's condescending to say olive
garden
and what did he say the hilton garden
inn or whatever anderson cooper said
that maybe that's condescending it's
certainly uh not going to bring anybody
who's not already
on anderson's side over to it that i i
would absolutely concede
um but tucker carlson does something
that is arguably even more pernicious
which is he he pretends so
let me see how to word this the right
way tucker i believe is also the heir to
something
and tucker does this pernicious
populist rhetoric which then he gets the
solutions
that are like you know so we got to do
something to prevent black lives matter
from taking your house and brown
immigrants
from making us a poor and dirty country
right
so what anderson cooper said is just
flat out condescending
and and probably unproductive although
generally speaking
i agree with the olive garden comment um
what tucker does is pretend that he is
the opposite
by using this faux populist rhetoric and
actually tricking his audience so
i don't know i would argue what tucker
does is far worse
anderson's comment is a plain comment
anderson's a rich guy
and he sort of made a condescending
comment about olive garden okay that
that's it that's it's fully exposed he's
not using faux populist rhetoric to
trick people and then giving them
horrible solutions to their problems
that
tend to be about you know the things
that tucker
suggests tucker's doing something much
more insidious i
i would argue okay anyway let's continue
did you appreciate that hope so
but the point is there are two standards
one that applies to you and the other
that applies to the pasty pink haired
antifa riders they can do whatever they
want
they of course will go back to sag by
the way like is that productive
paste pasty pink haired antifa rioters
that and but this was a trump riot
harbor at the end of the day and stay
with their parents is totally fine but
trump supporters
they're insurrectionists they should be
hunted down tucker is doing the same
thing right i mean that's that's a class
attack
that's a class attack saying that the
left-wing protesters don't have the
finances to be out on their own that's
the exact
attack
am i am i missing something here there's
20 seconds between tucker attacking
anderson for saying olive garden
and he makes the exact same attack that
the left wingers are unemployed living
in their parents basement
this is so stupid today
cnn unveiled a soviet-style enemies list
to make it a little easier to find all
those trump supporters
and then destroy them and next we will
roll the tape
on all of the president's enablers who
are all helped
to who have all helped to fuel the
deadly insurrection
at the u.s capitol man that is a jeff
zucker order if there ever was it's
actually from the fbi
the fbi said we need to identify these
people what so this is that's a really
really stupid commentary by tucker
carlson wherein
he starts to get to a kernel of a fair
criticism that anderson's comment was
condescending
but he does something far worse every
day
but then he does the exact same thing
he's criticizing anderson for so that's
really weird
and then there's this other one i've
been told is worth watching
this is uh oh sorry hold on people
people want to be thanked
18 26. all right so we've got plus seven
as far as twitch goes which puts us at
80
and then 24 okay so that's another
four on the website putting us at 84
members
uh thanks very much i appreciate that
wait 84.
there it is perfect okay let's do um
let's go to this next clip this is
tucker last night i guess a very short a
four-minute interview with marco rubio
let's listen
rubio represents the state of florida
now the most popular state in the
country we notice he joins us tonight
after having watched
all of this again to you senator by the
way thank you for coming
what are you thinking terrible what do
you make of it it's one of the
well i think it's one of the saddest
days in our in our modern history
probably in our history
i think it doesn't i think they're
high-fiving in beijing
and the chinese look at this and and are
very happy about it it kind of
bolsters their claim that we're falling
apart and they're they're the country of
the future
fair so far so good i think it's
inexcusable completely 100 excusable i
don't care what the motivations and then
obviously you know people are going to
get arrested we're going to learn more
about who was there and what this was
all about and i think
it'll it'll be interesting to see is
this confusing to tucker tucker already
looks confused it's weird
these are the mix of people that were
there and so forth i think it's been
tragic and i want to say something i
want to thank the capitol police
officers we know a lot of these people
personally we walked by them every
single day who had to go out there and
do this and
we're really um under man for you know
overwhelmed by this at one point in time
but um but you know and so none of it is
an excuse now i do think that
one of the challenges we have is we have
a serious crisis of confidence in this
country there is now literally no
individual or institution in this
country that can speak definitively
about anything
well but so and and but hold on we can
definitively say joe biden won the
election see that
this is where they speak in coded
language where anybody can take away
from this what they want
um that's right that marco did get so
depending on what you want to listen for
if you still want to keep marco
on your nice list right what you're
hearing is
oh he's saying this all happened because
we can't actually trust the election
results that's what you hear
and you're arguably not wrong because
he's deliberately wording it
and using a statement that you could
interpret in exactly that way if that's
what you mean
and i and that's not an excuse for any
of this but it explains
some of the things that create typically
when you say it's not an excuse
you're making an excuse an environment
that lead to this all across the board
and the media is shocked you know that
that they've they have zero credibility
they're there
oh and then he throws that in yeah
that's actually one that's been spread
so he's really hitting all the all the
um
bullet points that they've come up with
for the last 24 hours which is
a lot of the problem is the media
reporting on the riots
right i mean okay listen trump's been
inciting people for two months about a
stolen
election um and then he literally said
at 12 30 we're gonna march to the
capitol
and then at one they marched to the
capitol
but the media reporting on this stuff
that you know that's
there's been irresponsible reporting
there so this is this is the
this is the playbook they've developed
over the last 24 hours
viewed largely as biased then you have
the censoring of
news stories before an election uh by
the social media companies
and and so and then you have these
questions that in normal i'm guessing
he's talking about
does that mean the hunter biden store is
he is he making the case that the hunter
biden story
uh was censored is that the case i mean
it's like oh just about everybody looked
into it and it was without merit so
at some point how long ago how long are
you going to report on that story
normal times people would look at be
able to work through but in that
environment of lack of confidence really
sparks up and
and i think those things need to be
answered because elections democracy
doesn't just depend on having elections
and depends on people's confidence in
those elections
right and their willingness to abide by
those results they're interrelated
i don't know why the senate so so here i
mean listen he's defending
this is this is marco rubio getting as
close as he can to codedly defending the
riots
while saying out of the other side of
his mouth that violence is always bad
right uh he he's saying
these are the direct results when what
really matters
is that we have elections people can
trust because when they don't trust them
this is what happens but violence is bad
the violence is bad and it was a really
sad day but listen we can't trust any
institution
and when you don't trust the
institutions then this is what happens
and that's logical but it's bad
can't do watergate style titanic style
hearings
uh we could take testimony subpoena
records i wouldn't change the outcome of
this race but it would give people the
clarity the answer
and by the way the changes that we need
to make when i was in florida in the
legislature i served on a task force
after 2000 that made a bunch of changes
to the mechanics of our elections
and um and i think we could do that for
the country
i wonder i i wondered all day what
republicans in the senate made of this
so people came to your place of work
and i'm not talking personally i am
really despised by an awful lot of
people and every once in a while i think
to myself
they have good reason to despise me
maybe i can communicate differently i
mean
it does it should evoke some soul
searching in the person who's despised a
little bit
and i wonder if republican senators are
thinking to themselves tonight
i hate the vandalism i hate the violence
i hate all this crap on the other hand
a lot of my voters really hate me maybe
i should change the way i behave
do you think anyone's thinking that well
i
i certainly think there's two things
that have to happen first we have to
actually kind of an interesting question
sounds like marco's not going to answer
it from his first five words here firmly
say that this stuff's not acceptable it
just can't happen i mean
i couldn't agree we look like an animal
we look like the third world
i mean honestly we look like the therma
this is stuff that you see in another
country
we've got ten pot dictators out there
lecturing us and
trump's a wannabe dictator and he's
talking about other i mean that's that's
actually
pretty wild mocking us you know in their
twitter feeds and online so
that stuff can't happen the second thing
i would make is at some point
everyone's got to step back here and
realize that this has been brewing and
building for a while and it's all across
the board no it's not really across the
no see so right so this is this is the
last
page of the playbook for the last 24 to
48 hours which is
let's just denounce everything and say
that this has been building everywhere
no no
this specifically was precipitated if
donald trump remember
at 2 am on wednesday morning the night
of the election
donald trump came out and said i won
what you won and and it's been downhill
from there the rudy giuliani uh the
flatulence and him
you know potentially passing coveted by
flatulence and sydney powell
and jenna ellis and you know it's just
been humiliating ever since
culminating with let's go to the capitol
so it's not
it's been building but this is a very
specific event
and of course it's built on
pseudo-intellectualism and
anti-intellectualism lack of media
literacy lack of education people who
don't understand wait a second this
these claims are idiotic of course the
election wasn't stolen
um but this is so now it's like oh we
got to come together and denounce it all
and and there are real factors out there
that are contributing not just to an
erosion of confidence and trust in
america
but some of the writing you made a point
and i caught the tail end of it and it's
absolutely right
there is no such thing as a country in
which you know half of us
are very happy and the other half is
very unhappy it just it can't ha it
can't work
none of us is going anywhere so we're
gonna have to figure out a way to
coexist
that's always been the challenge in
america the country that now it's all
about coexisting
now it's all about coexisting okay and
then lastly let's get to the dan
crenshaw one he also appeared
so we want to where did he appear he
appeared with martha mccallum
uh yeah we'll get to that in him we'll
get to that in a moment
uh so that this is you know the these
are
everybody's playing exactly the role we
would expect them to play
um thanks to moose stuff and the other
four folks who just signed up via twitch
i i really do appreciate that and then
also thanks to
um morton damsliff
and carl merritt who signed up at
joinpakman.com putting us at 91 we are
close to opening the phone lines if
folks want the phone lines opened
we are we are getting dangerously close
at 91 out of 100 website members
let's listen now to martha mccallum's
interview of dan
crenshaw um and i've been told by i
haven't watched any of these in advance
i've been told that he made some actual
okay points here let's see
you bring this to you now as republican
senators who objected to the electoral
college count now face a fury
of some on the left who are making a
dramatic leap linking them to violence
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
tweeted this quote senator cruz you must
accept responsibility
for how dramatic link linking them to
violent how is that
it's obvious how is that dramatic your
craven self-serving actions contributed
to the deaths of four people yesterday
and how you fundraised off this riot
both you and senator hawley must resign
if you do not the senate
should move for your expulsion she says
republican congressman
dan crenshaw of texas joins me now
congressman always good to have you with
us thanks for being here tonight
um so this that's just one i mean you've
got joaquin castro beto o'rourke
representative joe moody telerico all of
these
uh government officials making very
similar statements
uh calling them seditionists and saying
there's blood on their hands essentially
yeah let me be as clear as possible here
so senator cruz and holly i disagree
with them
in the in a fundamental way about the
constitutionality of this process on
january 6 the ability
of congress to overturn any electoral
votes period
but let's be very honest senator cruz
and senator hawley were not hyping up
january 6th
they were not calling for people to
fight in the streets they were not
saying this was our last stand
right but so so what what dan crenshaw
misses here i actually
we have to go back to what justin
trudeau said we said it perfectly um
cruz and hawley uh created the space
for trump to do what he did and you
don't have to you know this is not like
but chaos theory where a butterfly
flapping its wings in china
has some creates a hurricane in florida
right this is not that type of stuff
this continued to build because
people started bowing to the pressure of
trump
uh to challenge results when josh hawley
said i plan to stand up and object then
ted cruz said i plan to stand up and
object
and that gave trump the momentum to go
to georgia on monday night and to talk
about the objections and to pressure
pence
and to then go to a rally on wednesday
morning knowing the objections were
going to come
and to say that they're going to march
to the capitol so
the the the idea that cruz and holly
bear no responsibility
in the incitement is wrong because they
they fomented trump's behavior
if every republican simply says no
no uh you don't get this riot because
trump doesn't do what he did so i think
that dan crenshaw
is either misunderstanding or being
disingenuous here and
that being said many members of congress
did do that
many commentators did do that many in
the media have been doing that for the
last few weeks constantly
saying this is our time to fight and let
me tell you something very clearly
they've been lying to people
they've been lying to millions okay
they've been lying that january 6 was
going to be this big solution for
election integrity it never was going to
be
i mean two hours of debate forced two
hours of debate that was just some time
for some opportunistic politicians
to get five minutes of time on the floor
true very true it was never going to
solve anything and it was always
unconstitutional
you have to have these hard battles one
at the state level that's where the hard
work is done that's how you solve the
important question of election integrity
and they lied to people and they said go
fight go fight because everything's on
the line that's what they said and when
people
fought they came to fight and then they
everything he's saying is right i just
disagree that the republican senators
are
are guiltless here i think everything
he's saying
applies to cruz and holly and everybody
who gave space for this to build
bought capital police and now people are
dead and those same members of congress
who called people to fight well they
were nowhere to be found
because it was all fun and games to them
they never knew what a real fight was
real fights are scary
bullets flying that's scary the glass
breaking that's really scary they were
nowhere to be found they scattered
they'd been talking about the courage to
stand up to this the courage to fight
for weeks and weeks but when it came
down to it there was no courage
that's what really happened martha and
that's what people need to know they
were lied to
they were lied to about what january 6
was that's true but but listen
cruz cruz was uh where was it um
oh i don't know if it was ted cruz being
interviewed by laura ingram
or what it was cruz was actually saying
january 6
could be something so crenshaw's
analysis
is essentially correct except
that he says crews and other senators
weren't participating in it they were
they were absolutely participating in it
election integrity is important
it has been important to me since the
day i entered congress
but i know that i'm not going to lie to
you i'm going to tell you where we
actually have to do the hard work and we
have to
change these laws at the state level
because these laws are
loose they don't give people any
confidence people are getting ballots
that don't belong to them there's no
voter id no signature verification
we hear you we hear you but we have to
come together
and work at the state level and change
these things
i don't think he could be said any
better than that um
congressman crenshaw thank you all right
so you know he makes some fair points
the things he wants to see done at the
state level are essentially bogus
and he's wrong that the senators didn't
have a role to play so that's sort of
like that that's
that's kind of the summation um of the
of the entire thing and by the way yes
as has been pointed out
have you seen a picture of dan
crenshaw's district
if if you want to get a sense of of
problems with election integrity
dan crenshaw district
look at this this is dan crenshaw's
district
okay is that a a compact
district right so so if you want to fix
things at the state level
don't you have to fix this uh i mean
this
this is just lunacy this is complete and
total lunacy
um so anyway the things he wants to fix
at the state level i don't know
i don't know that that's something that
uh that he wants to fix
necessarily but anyway okay listen we we
listened to dan crenshaw
and uh that that was his perspective i
do want to say
thanks to the 19 folks who just grabbed
um twitch subscriptions which puts us at
110
and also with the addition of terry
lilly tanika savage
or savage shane simpson
pam jones and wesley chisholm
we are at 115 so i
i will open up the discord lines a bit
and hear from a few folks i do want to
hear from some folks
you can get a hold of me by going to
davidpakman.com
discord and getting in the waiting lobby
once again putting a parentheses at the
front of your name
will get you skipped over it's a cheap
tactic to get your name at the top of
the list
i don't go in order anyway i'm bored and
and annoyed
by the use of parentheses to put
yourselves at the top of the list
so we skip those those are skipped right
away
let's go to uh i see everybody now
changing that very very interesting
let's go to robin from scotland
robin from scotland you're our first
caller today
hi david hi how are you oh okay how are
you
doing well i don't actually have
anything to ask i just wanted to weigh
in on the
juice debate you did yes okay yeah right
right the
soda what is soda what is soda called in
scotland
you're breaking up a little robin but i
do want you to clear it up
sorry go ahead
and we i call it fizzy dress mostly and
but i do know a lot of people that call
it ginger as well
right so i would go and say i want a
coke ginger or i want a fanta ginger or
i want a root beer ginger
no no you just say like if it is
something specific you say
um like i want a fanta or a cola or a
sprite but
if it's just like everything in general
you call it fizzy juice
i see so when you go to the fizzy juice
aisle
there is coke there's sprite there's
seven up all of that stuff would be
under the category of fizzy juice
yeah perfect all right i understand that
now that makes sense
it's a little off but it's it does sort
of make sense now just one other thing
just to complete the conversation we
started yesterday with a different
caller
um in uh when when i say
that thing at school where you drink
water
do you call that a water fountain a
bubbler a water bubbler
a faucet what do you call that um
probably just
a water phone n a water fountain okay
very good i like that that's that's what
i call it as well
all right robin thank you a real
pleasure i appreciate that thank you
so we cleared it up and see that was
perfectly clear i really understood that
that made perfect sense to me
um all right let's go next to
i know it's getting late for some folks
so let's go for example to sophie in
london but i'm sophie i'm guessing you
have to go to bed soon so i want to get
to you right away
hi can you hear me yes i can hi
um i actually don't plan on going to bed
soon but um
oh all right well then let me put you on
hold for an hour okay
now go ahead sophie thank you for
picking up uh i really enjoy
your videos it's fun to keep updated
from across the pond
um i was just wondering i had on the
news today that um
or it was an article that some people
some trump supporters were actually
turning against trump because he didn't
you know
appreciate their act of loyalty
by storming the capital so i was just
wondering if
you think that's an actual trend that's
going to happen or if that's just
it's i think that you're going to see a
lot of everything there's people
abandoning and you're seeing that happen
with voters and you're also seeing that
happen with some of trump's cabinet but
then there are people that are committed
to going down with the ship so like
betsy devos bailed but there's 12 days
to go you know who cares
on the other hand kaylee mcinanni seems
to be devoted to going down with the
ship
so you'll see examples of everything i
don't know that there's
not everybody will abandon him but not
everybody will stick with him
it's such a big country with so many
people that there will be a little of
everything
yeah yeah exactly um i actually studied
american politics um
as part of my a level so i wish i had
discovered your videos
tell me about a level is a level is a
level college
um i think so so you take the actual
exam when you're 18. i obviously didn't
this
well i was supposed to have taken it in
may of 2020 um
but that was obviously cancelled due to
covid so
maybe a level is more like ap classes in
the us
um possibly i think is your ged i think
that's similar to gcrc here
ged ged is an alter if you don't finish
high school
you can study and take a ged test
which will give you an equivalency to
high school if you've not actually
gotten a high school degree so it's like
it's basically like
similar to a high school diploma oh
okay that might be more like a b-tech
then um anyway
i digress wow um are you for or against
blood sausage
oh god um i have never had it
really some people thoroughly enjoy it
though so
are you vegetarian is that are you do
you just not eat meat you're not
vegetarian definitely not
i just i don't think i've ever i don't
know
i i think people think that's a very
british thing but you don't really
maybe maybe in the odds for english you
might find that blood sausage is
actually huge in argentina
oh that's interesting oh wait a second
wait a second
is it am i calling it is it black
pudding am i using the wrong name for it
i yeah it's the same thing it's the same
thing okay yeah but even as blood
pudding you've still not had it
no i have i have seen it and some people
do enjoy it but um
i can't personally say that it's
something i'd be
wanting to try that's completely fair
yeah i uh you know i don't eat pork
anymore so i'm off the blood
sausage but as a kid i loved it i'm
gonna i'm not gonna lie i loved it as a
kid
maybe i should uh try out then yeah all
right well sophie i appreciate the call
thank you
thanks for talking to me today all right
very good um
very very strong call let's go
next to um
[Music]
let's go to is this andrew from
charleston
south carolina or andre i can't see the
full name oh that's me
how are you hey yeah can you hear me yes
i can
hello hey man i just wanted to jump on
i saw you're doing a live stream i've
been listening for a while thank you
probably about six years now i've loved
the show
wow a member probably like
last year when you were having all those
issues with youtube and your perfect
revenue so thank you i'll give you a
hand i appreciate it um so
i got a question for you just kind of
about the future of what's going on
um in the country here um it seems like
things are kind of getting really
aggressive yes
like very quickly um and it
it seems like it's not going to stop
like that this seems to be a beginning
point
unless you know people in power start to
really shift their attitudes and start
doing something
like actually bringing justice and
making people accountable
i i agree with you and that's why it's
so important that you know now we're
starting to hear about people getting
fired
after they've been identified by their
employers by the way how funny is it
that there's people worried about
uh being microchipped with a covid
vaccine to be tracked
and then they wear their work badge to
the insurrection so that's just that's
funny
but i think you know the arrests have to
happen the firings have to happen
ideally as close to unanimous
denouncement of what took place by all
leaders should happen because
otherwise they'll just do it again
they'll be encouraged to do it again
yeah yeah i think so and one other thing
um you know i mean i live in charleston
south carolina i actually
was kind of close to where they had that
big um shooting that happened
at that uh amy church right um with
dylan roof
yes um do you i mean that's always
something that's kind of in the back of
my mind is like you know these mass
shootings kind of like
happening again and kind of coming back
up do you think that like
with the increase in violence that we
are going to start seeing
that we have already seen is this going
to make any movement in terms of gun
control like is biden gonna
finally do something in this country no
i actually i i worry that
what has taken place is you know one of
the things that i'm predicting is that
as republicans want to distance from
trump
they will go back to all of their normal
pet projects which include pretending to
care about the debt and deficit
focusing on their very narrow myopic
view of what religious freedom means
and talking about how democrats are
coming for your guns and you know
something that's very very interesting
um is that and disgusting
democratic presidents are great for gun
sales and the reason that they're great
for gun sales
is that you see republicans and
the gun lobby uh encourage gun purchases
because the democrat is just
five days from taking your guns and so
you gotta go out and buy them and we saw
record gun sales under barack obama
and um yeah i mean i think that uh i i
think it's
it's going to be um it's not i don't
expect to see much progress on gun
control unfortunately but
but uh i hope that i'm wrong
yeah that i mean that kind of scares me
i mean especially going into the first
year of joe biden that
i mean a lot of these crazies now
they're just they're still just as crazy
and they're to get themselves armed and
now they're just going to be aggressive
and they're going to continue to get
aggressive and
continue to push the limits it seems
absolutely yeah i like i don't want to
be the one walking around with all these
crazies i mean especially down here in
the south like
everyone around here has a gun it's just
yeah i mean but then you know what i
know a lot of uh
i know a lot of people on the left and
i've said before i'm not
i'm not really talking about my own
relationship to firearms because i just
don't think
there's any advantage to it but i'll
just i'll make it a sort of abstract
thing
there's a lot of people on the left who
don't want it to be just the right
wingers with the guns
and have armed themselves over the last
year as well
yeah my brother he that's the same
argument he gives me he's he's kind of
like a left-winger like liberal like me
but he's like
a staunch gun owner and i'm like man i
wish it was some other way but
i just i don't see any path forward
other than you know
can we do it's unfortunately a race to
the bottom you know it's unfortunate
it's sort of like a nuclear arms race
right where where you say well
i'd rather there be fewer guns but they
have so many we should get some
too and then it you know it's a very
similar mechanism
yeah just too many exist like you know
like at this point it's like you're not
going to be able to
remove all of them from america at this
point and that's a factor in talking
about police as well hey
we would love it for police for not all
police to carry firearms maybe you just
have a special squad like in some
countries well
when there's 350 million guns out there
in the hands of civilians
how do you say well the police shouldn't
have them you have to deal with the gun
ownership problem first
yeah yeah it's like a tangled mess it is
it is yeah but babe
man thanks thanks for thanks for taking
my call today i'll um
love the show i'll still i'll i'll keep
uh
keep tuning in all right beautiful phone
call thank you so much i appreciate it
um let's go next to um
there's there's just so many people here
to talk to
i want to try to a lot of folks i
recognize i'd like to get to some new
voices if at all possible um
we have uh oh let's go to
let's go to jose from miami florida
hey david can you hear me i can it would
be good if you can silence your discord
so we don't hear the discord blinging
throughout the call
okay i believe do not disturb is the
the the feature you would like
which feature sorry go go ahead jose
maybe we can get to maybe
maybe it won't go off and we can get to
your question it might be simpler than
finding the button
okay sorry but you know i have
uh family members that are in queue and
on and i love that
they're in q anon did you say no
into the theories into into okay yeah
yeah yeah
i'm wondering if the if impeaching
oh my god solution concerning that
there's some
in regards oh boy jose i'm sorry jose
you're you're breaking up you're coming
through in fits and starts
you're saying you're you're unsure about
impeaching trump i'm guessing because
it'll fire up the q in on people
yes basically so yeah sorry i addressed
that earlier
i think that impeach it is impeachment
is a duty
it is not something you calculate i
think that it has to be
it has to be handled in those terms and
it is relatively rare that a president
does something worthy of impeachment
and when they do we don't say well it's
kind of the end of the term or
the q anon people might get mad it's if
if impeachment is appropriate it is a
duty to impeach
okay all right say i'm gonna let you go
because it's it's a um
i i'm i actually think that that that
connection is illegal in some states
florida it is legal fortunately so
you've not broken any laws but
um it's it's pretty scary stuff let's go
next to um why don't we go
let's go to it's either levy or levi
from washington
levy levi from washington you're on the
air oh hello
david it sounded like you just spit in a
bucket do you have a spit bucket
no i don't sounded like a spittoon like
a cartoon noise of a spittoon
see yeah anyway go ahead
yeah david hey uh big fan of the show um
thank you for your coverage
pleasure um i'm in a
deeply red area of washington state so
it kind of helps keep me sane to uh
watch your show and realize there are
rational people out there thank you
anyway i don't really have too much to
say um
as far as topical but i would weigh in
on i have an opinion on what
makes a sandwich oh okay go ahead yeah
i think it's only a sandwich if you
slice the bread
um nah i don't think i don't think that
works i don't think that works because
i've never heard anyone deny that a
grinder or a sub
or a hero depending on where it is that
you live
is not a sandwich and very often you're
only partially slicing into the
roll
hello true true i guess it's just a half
slice in that case
yeah so i don't know i'm not sure i'm
liking your definition
well i had to try yeah uh i mean i think
it's one of those things where you kind
of know it when you see it you know
yeah yeah and you know the other thing
is by the way open
open-faced sandwich right i mean like
what does that even mean
[Laughter]
yeah it's just a pile of stuff on a
piece of bread yeah and
also by your definition a quesadilla in
a sense is a sandwich too
that's true yeah i don't know i think
we've got to keep work
we got to continue workshopping it
yeah i'll do more research okay thanks
yeah call me back
okay thanks all right thanks very much
uh really really um
it is a it's a controversy i don't know
that it's really one for the ages i
don't know that it'll ever be uh
it'll ever be resolved um
this is kind of interesting i'm curious
about this let's go to
bitdefender from cancun mexico you're on
the air
hello david yes how are you what is what
do you mean
bit defender what is the deal with that
that's
well um it's a bit hard to explain but i
keep it for unanimity reasons it's your
handle we can say
yeah exactly and you r you you really uh
you live in cancun
yeah i'm a public servant in cancun i
was born here you're did you say you're
a public servant
yes you're like an elected official down
there
um not elected but i serve the
government in many ways wow well thank
you for your service what can i uh what
can i do for you
i actually had a question um
i i have to ask the chat is wondering
are you hitting yourself
in the head with a mallet right now
no you're not okay all right go there's
a very strange it sounds almost like a
percussive wood block
oh i'm sorry i'm really not sure what
that is no it's very interesting
it's very interesting oh i i think it's
a discord
thing for the push to talk actually oh
dear god
okay wow yeah i'm sorry i'll just keep
um anyway the question is the the
mexican president and es manuel lopez
obrador
is commonly often compared to bernie
sanders in many ways
yes um both by u.s and mexican analysts
so i i don't agree with that comparison
for multiple reasons
but i would like to hear your opinion on
that if you have any
i i i'd be lying if i said i know enough
to be able to compare
in detail but my instinct is that the
comparison is
is probably not appropriate and and the
reason why
is would be less about the specifics
of obrador but more about the fact that
latin american leftism is is quite
different
than than sort of like american bernie
type social democracy
so my instinct would be that like at a
systemic level there's probably some
some uh non-trivial differences
i would definitely agree actually um
many mexicans regard andes manuel lopez
obrador as a leftist
version leftist mexican version of trump
right oh that's that's
i've not heard that no yeah
it's essentially the same populist
tactics you know lying to the public
creating a grand narrative
and then being completely incompetent at
governing the country itself
yeah but you know like
i guess some people too much
interested in making a comparison along
the the traditional
right left um you know spectrum
let me research more and and so i could
be better informed about it
absolutely i hope no talk to you again
soon hey real quick um so i've been to
cancun many many times actually
um i was told you know when when i
stayed at the at my hotel
we i found some restaurants in downtown
that i wanted to try
and when we went to the hotel front desk
and explained where we wanted to go
they seemed horrified like tourists
don't go downtown but i went downtown
and it seemed perfectly fine and safe
is it that rare that tourists don't go
downtown cancun
well it's not rare for tourists to go to
downtown cancun
actually the the downtown part of the
city has been
ever more welcoming to tourists um
however i cannot lie in saying like i in
my line of work
i work with tourists that precisely have
encountered problems you know with
either criminal activity or
otherwise here so
ultimately you know i know many many
cases of people that have
had things stolen or worse
but that's probably a very very small
percentage of the total
you know interesting i'm probably very
very biased in that sense because
it's all you're dealing with my job yeah
exactly
right interesting and then last thing
every time i've been down there there's
always
big concern about the water only don't
don't even brush your teeth with the tap
water
etc for the locals are you
uh biologically accustomed to the water
where you can drink it
it's a good question we don't drink tap
water in mexico in general
like throughout the country we don't
have the systems that the us has in
place
like the you put some element into the
water i think it's flooring
um we don't have that here we drink
you know big bottles of 20 liters of
water
that we buy on a regular basis got him
and they get replaced right
yeah um in regards to hotel tap water i
guess it's really a roll of the dice
i've never
heard of anybody getting sic sick from
brushing their teeth
usually it's you know making the mistake
of
drinking the water thinking that it's
just like in the u.s
right um and you they usually drink a
lot of water so that's
you know it's not no surprise yeah um
but some hotels have those systems
internally in place and they will have a
little plaque that says that you can
drink the tap water
well you know i actually went to um are
you familiar with the restaurant in the
hotel zone
puerto malero it's an argentinian
restaurant of course yeah of course
yeah when i was there and of course i
was chatting up with the waiters in in
argentinian castellano
um they were saying that the entire
hotel zone or
or much of it on boulevard kukulkan
actually has a water filtrate a water a
purification system that you can
actually drink the water up and down the
entire thing
i i they weren't trying to get me to
drink tap water but they were mentioning
it and i don't know whether that's
that's true or not i am
doubtful at best okay so they may have
been lying to me yeah you know
general general system i am very
doubtful because i know
i know how that
is organized and i really doubt that
they use
drinkable water for interest the whole
hotel zone
now donald trump warned us that under
joe biden we would have to flush the
toilet 10 or 15 times
is that a problem in cancun
well it might be for some tourists that
come
here and have some of the food okay
they're not used to
it understood understood you're right
all right very good um okay i really
appreciate the call
since you man all right very good and
they boink
to you as well very interesting
cartoonish boink noise there
um apparently generated by uh generated
by discord
let's go to jeeves in anaheim california
jeeves
david how are you doing today how are
you i'm doing very well thank you
thank you first time first time caller
long time i guess watcher
pleasure so yeah so i appreciate you
taking the call um i
had a quick question um uh you were
speaking earlier about um i guess media
literacy and being able to determine
um i guess what's good actual journalism
versus
i'm just entertainment posing as
journalism sure um
you know being able to like critically
think between those two
those things um so i guess i was
wondering on your thoughts
on things like uh the fcc fairness
doctrine and whether something like that
might um like bring that back
might help or if it's you know a bigger
issue where we need to
where it's like an education problem
uh it's interesting i've gotten a bunch
of questions about the um
fairness doctrine in the last week and i
think that the the
the opportunity for the fairness
doctrine to fix the problems we have
that ship has sort of sailed
particularly because
the fairness doctrine was focused on uh
the the airwaves and regulation of the
airwaves
with the internet you'd need a totally
different infrastructure if that's your
approach but that is not the approach i
would take i would take an approach of
uh cultural and educational change okay
yeah it's i i'm kind of like um
i guess a lot of a lot of us have been
asking the question like how do we
you know how do we
fix this problem how do we how do we get
people to yeah like
see what's going on and uh to me it just
it really seems that it's a like we have
to
kind of prepare for a like this is gonna
be a long
long fight there's nothing that that's
going to exactly like
overnight change things and we just have
to accept that it took 40 years to get
into this mess it's not gonna be undone
in six months
okay yeah cool is there do you have any
perk do you have any percussive
instrument you could play while you talk
a cowbell maybe or a set of hi-hats uh i
i used to be a
a professional vocal percussionist for a
a cappella group
interesting oh that's interesting so i'm
going to do some like vocal percussion
what's the trick to that vocal
percussion in acapella groups
um so i'm sure when you were a kid
like you would just like make weird
sounds with your mouth mm-hmm
you basically do that but as an adult oh
okay all right
and then yeah yeah so just like
yeah that kind of like beautiful all
right we're gonna remix that all right
excellent all right thanks so much for
the call thank you david that's
jeeves from anaheim wow
um okay let's see who else we've got
here
uh we're taking a few calls
let's go to let's go to alicia who is
argentinian
hey can you hear me yes i can uh it's uh
it's elisha sorry
oh okay it's like alicia it's all good
now i'm guessing so that's that you you
don't live in argentina
yeah i lived there i grew up there for
for five years five six years
of my life no but i mean you don't live
you don't live there now
i i i'm going back there uh in a couple
months for
for about six months really yeah where'd
you yeah where'd you grow up there
buenos aires
i've never been i've never been that's
interesting yeah i mean i keep
thinking of just once the once the whole
pandemic is over
setting up shop there and setting up my
studio and just doing six months in
buenos aires you know
totally do that yeah yo so i had a
question a
big fan obviously um i'm probably gonna
grab a subscription
i just i just can't not do that you know
it's impossible not to it's impossible
right exactly yeah so but i had a
question you know
i i got into it after this this
insurrection coup attempt you know
the third day i got into my family and i
come from a super conservative family
i'm definitely the black sheep of the
family you know
but i got into it them and and i just
wanted to know if you
you have a suggestion for what
what you can do and then the best way is
to deal you know interact with your
family
politically if they're completely on
their spectrum
uh it i i've answered this question for
people who are in
similar situations and my advice is
really it depends on what you want your
relationship with them to be like
honestly
yeah if you are if you are okay ruining
the relationship
then the answer is to how you talk about
politics is one thing
if you want not to do that then the
answer is something else
and in general i think the best way to
talk about politics with family that
disagrees in a way that is less likely
to cause chaos
with the highest chance of changing
their minds is to just
keep at rather than making judgments and
telling them that they're wrong
regularly ask them how they figured how
they came to a certain belief
what would change their mind and and
with some people they will come to
realize the foundation on which i built
a lot of these beliefs is not so good
yeah great advice and again i i
mentioned this book yesterday and i'll
mention it again
one of the great pieces of of advice
from dale carnegie's book how to win
friends and influence people
is let people think they came up with
the ideas that are that you actually
want to convince them of
because that is one of the things people
are most likely to go with
uh if they say i came up with this
that's much better than
i had to admit i was wrong to someone
else
yeah yeah true awesome well thank you
appreciate that
all right my pleasure uh thanks for the
call yeah bye
okay bye uh very very good similar to me
uh argentinian who came to the u.s
at age five that's that's compelling
stuff um
let's go to edmundo from lima peru you
know edmund
i just watched there's this great new
netflix show
street food latin america and yesterday
i watched the episode on lima
hello how are you hi how are you wow
it's really awesome to be here thank you
for having me thank you uh
well yeah uh in fact my question
was uh what's basically about our food
really to you so the thing is this
we have like like you know
we have really amazing food in peru like
astonishingly amazing we have
like a great variety of of um
uh i don't know how to say this um
vegetables
uh i mean food ingredients
right yes the the the base ingredients
are very high quality yeah so
uh in the last six months we had
two major protests here in peru
one at november
i i i don't remember the the exact date
but it was like
fifth november okay uh it was about
the president the well we it's a really
long story but
long story short we had a president
until
november then he got kicked out by the
congress
the congress er depression the president
of the congress
took the power but the people didn't
didn't want
that so we went out to the streets
and we basically kicked him out right
okay
so that that was that that's an entirely
um complete issue apart from what i was
talking about
but the thing is that the second protest
was made by
um labor people
people who worked on a
labor activists yeah well i i'm going to
tell you
in spanish i know that you know spanish
oh okay so yes agricultural workers yeah
okay so
i wasn't sure about that so the thing is
uh about the process in lima
the media cover it like really really
tightly uh we were supported by the
media
we which was kind of weird but
on the second protest which was far
uh on my on my side it was far more
important
because uh these these workers were
paid and far less
than the minimum wage i i mean we have
like a minimum wage of 80
50 850 solas right
so these people were were getting paid
like 700 solas and considering extra
hours of work
of labor yes so it was like really
really serious especially for us
we peruvians are very proud of about our
gastronomy
yes so it was kind of weird in that
second process because the media
didn't care the jews didn't care we
helped
a lot of people died on on both protests
but
on the first one they were heroes and on
the second one they were
like rioters like like really bad people
yeah which one care
it was really hurtful
i would say i i feel ashamed of
of that kind of culture that we are
having right now
i understand yeah i did not i'm not
familiar enough to say too much more
other than that
i would be it would not be shocking to
me that different groups of protesters
are treated in different ways by the
media
sometimes the groups of protesters are
also behaving differently as we saw here
in the united states i don't know enough
about it to be able to say much more
yeah my question was about because i i
kind of feel
some similarities about what what you
were talking about
about the protest on the on the capital
yeah versus the protest about
black lives matter right so what do you
think
will be the right approach like on on
maybe uh talking to the people
like by social media like
i don't know if it's it's correct to
just
um making sure that a lot of people know
about the situation of
or maybe that's contra productive i i'm
not really sure what to do
like on my own like myself what to do to
at least change that situation a bit
you know i'm not actually sure what
situation is
oh okay so yeah okay so this is this is
a good question which is
the the dif there are so dramatic
differences between
the black lives matter george floyd
protests and the violent insurrection
but there are some i'm interjecting now
my part of this
it's very cynical there is a very
cynical way in which we've seen
some kind of make them the same but also
sometimes they're covered differently
when in reality they are the same the
the answer is huge i mean it just
depends
it's a problem of changing the entire
media apparatus in the united states
media literacy education it's i
there's no it's not like hey if we get a
hashtag going we'll
everybody will understand what's going
on it's such a bigger issue than that
um so i unfortunately don't have the
answer but you've perfectly identified
the problem
yeah that's i i mean we like i said
we have we are very proud of of our
gastronomy
like really proud and the fact that the
people that are the major actors on our
gastronomy yeah
are being treated this way it's really
awful so that's horrible
i i know it's a different it's it's a
different scenario but
i kind of i kind of thought that
we could talk about that so thank you
listen i appreciate it i have i have one
quick question for you some people may
or may not know that
in peru there has been significant when
you look at asian immigration to latin
america
argentina for example tended to have
more chinese and korean
immigration whereas peru had more
japanese
immigration i'm i'm curious is
is it considered that there is
discrimination or racism against
japanese
in peru or do you feel that there's sort
of
more natural integration into peruvian
culture how
how is it okay so that's
like a big question maybe i i will have
to speak spanish for for okay
okay i mean the the big part is this
we don't usually uh there is no usually
racism
against foreign uh citizens
uh not japanese uh we have like a very
strong
african peruvian community so we don't
we there is some discrimination yeah but
that's not really the the big part of it
okay the biggest part of discrimination
in peru especially in the city where i
live which is lima
is against the people from the from the
andes from
i mean we call it sierra but it's not
really sierra it's the andes and the
the mountains on peru and are these are
these indigenous folks
yeah uh no not really indigenous i mean
some of the cities like for example
cusco is it's a really big city yeah
it's a really important city we have
machu picchu there
so um the fact that they are big
doesn't mean that the indigenous
population
gets treated better okay um we have
this war here you might if you might
have heard it about it in
in mexico it means a lot different in
peru
the world is cholo yes right so i travel
in mexico
i have some mexican friends and they
told me that it's like uh
like a street street person
yes yes yes like a bugler i don't know
yeah well that's the messi the mexican
approach uh
in our country cholo means that you come
from the andes
but it is used like uh
like an insult right if someone cuts you
solo
it means like he really wants to hurt
you
because you look different right because
you look like you came from the
from the mountains from the jordan
indigenous understood
it's really hard that part because most
of
of peruvians we have like
a really big mix of races in peru so
it's um we have we have this
this saying in peru it's it's in spanish
saying so
um
which will mean like if you if
well we all have some some
race mix in our blood that will be like
the meaning
um and it's very hard
for it it's very hard for for us like
um meets race uh guys like me
uh i am in fact like a big japanese i
i'm not really sure if
i have like a japanese ancestor but
like really asian looking
but the thing is that uh especially
against the people
from the end it's it's really hard for
them it's
uh i i've seen so
so very awful things done to them
and it's not even funny to to talk about
them
in a way that we try to to learn
it's it's not even a human way to treat
someone understood understood uh all
right good i appreciate the information
and uh really appreciate the call from
peru
thank you thank you debbie all right
very good i appreciate it see you around
yeah
uh okay good all right my friends um we
are at the two hour mark i plan to
stream for two hours and we've done it i
appreciate everybody who's joined me
this week
we i don't anticipate any weekend
streams but then we've got next week and
then of course then you know what's
happening on january 20th and we're
going to be covering all of that so
uh thanks to everybody who joined
chatted
make sure to follow me on twitch we've
had our best five-day period ever on
twitch it's been the last five days
make sure to subscribe if you're
watching on youtube because then you'll
be i guess notified about future streams
although it's not even clear that that
works anymore
uh but i'll talk to everybody very soon